[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on débat
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
comme on a perdu
la vie
dernière image en rade ou de la colle
c'est quand même en tenue de temps chez
un hôte la petite mon mouton est le truc
de rabbi jacob quand même là on est au
sommet du sommet accepter tout il
accepter tout et puis la danse tout ce
qui était festif moi j'ai rencontré
plusieurs fois en boîte de nuit habitait
il ya quelques années au gel à l'époque
j'ai année encore et il était là il a
néanmoins dit non non je veux plus notre
lit ça m'est passé a bondi sur elle
alors j'ai dit j'ai dit tu t'es coucher
tôt hier samedi oui je suis couché à une
heure jeudi basse états unis et
maintenant la veille je suis couché à 5h
casta foot jusqu'à 5 heures ce qui va
mal
[Applaudissements]
ils étaient comme des poissons comme des
poissons dans l'eau il avait énormément
de succès auprès des filles je suis très
attiré par les par les flèches comme
dana fait leur aura parce que vraiment
tout d'abord il était extrêmement
sympathique il refusa
vraiment